hello everyone this is Sergey Thea
speaking I'm going to be the newbie
geographer of Samuel Leeds so I
apologize for my English because clearly
this is not my first language so the
thing is that I know nothing about
property investment so I'm going to ask
some well if you can teach me the basics
of it and I'm going to film everything
and share the information with you guys
[Music]
anymore you don't need to do a job the
basic definition is if you've got
properties that are giving you a passive
income like a rent that covers your
basic living essentials then you're
financially free the best way to achieve
financial freedom in my mind is to
properly look number one it gives you
rent so if you have properties or
control properties you get a really nice
passive income from that number two is
properties are so excited because if you
own them they go up in value over time
if you have money in the bank the money
stays the same if anything is shrinks
because as inflation goes up the money
becomes worth less over time so
investing in property is good because
you you you the property value goes up
and you get rent the different what
there are different ways you can make
money in property number one basic lie
to that but I to let means that you buy
it to let it out
so it's basically the most simple
straightforward
it just means buy to rent so you've got
money you put it into a house you rent
it out and that's it
the next is hey Jenna HM o stands for
house of multiple occupancy that's like
the house that you live in mm-hmm which
is actually Alistair's house yeah you're
renting a room and then there's another
room and another room and another room
and the landlord or the investor gets
all of the rent it comes down to more
rent that's 350 plus 350 plus that's
1400 pounds that's a lot more money then
Alastair would get if you just rented it
out to one family
but but if you paid 650 and you moved in
you'd have to pay the bills yeah you'd
have to get furniture you'd have did
where is for you
you pay 350 you move in and it's already
all up and running yeah because in 2019
convenience cells
for you to go and get a rent up the
whole house it would more expensive more
hassle so that's why not only is HMOs a
really good way to make money but it's
also a really good product because
you're actually helping people next rent
to rent rent to rent is let's say you
find this house it's owned by Bob Bob
bought the house for maybe a hundred
thousand pound and it's on the market
he's renting it out to seven hundred
pound a month and you said hey Bob you
rent in your house out for seven hundred
pound a month so I'll give you 600 per
month but I just won't charge or
anything to manage the house I'm gonna
pay all the maintenance look after the
house you'll have no management fees you
give Bob six and depan a month
guaranteed rent so Bob chuckling but
then you rent the house out as a HMO huh
you can ruin the property is your number
owner yeah well you learn something new
so if I went to ham Sal if I went a
house and I paid Bob six hundred I rent
it for 1,400 I've obviously got costs to
pay but any profit is mine
that is bit is called being an
entrepreneur
next is lease option agreement that is a
cross between a renter n and a
buy-to-let because here's what you do
let's say you do a renter rent and you
say look I'll get you 600 pound a month
guaranteed but at the end of that
contract five years time I want an
option to buy that house you rent it for
a while and then at the end you might
yeah like a PCP contract with a car yeah
now the great thing about that is if you
buy a house now you have all the
benefits now but you pay for it later in
five years from now until five years
you've benefited from all the rent and
unlike cars cars shrinking value but
houses go up so you've got fixed price
but then after five years and it's not
worth more you can have it in the
contracts that unless it's gone up you
do not have to buy it yes yeah so they
have to sell it but you have the option
not the obligation to one that's called
a lease option agreement next serviced
accommodation you know when you rent a
house up with buy-to-let and you get a
very standard rent HMO it lifts the rent
because you're renting the rooms out
serviced accommodation is a way of
renting a property out and getting the
maximum wins and what you do you can
rent your house out and you can put your
house you can list it on air B&B and
booking.com
and then people come and they'll stay
for one night two nights two weeks but
they'll pay rather than paying sixteen
to pound a month they might pay one
hundred pound of nine and you can rent
houses out that way
you can do something called rent to
serviced accommodation which is where
you rent a house you pay bobbysocks and
open a month but then you turn the house
into a serviced accommodation house and
you keep all the difference makes sense
easy peasy
max deal packaging deal packaging is
when you find properties by two let's
HMOs renter aunts lease option agreement
service combination any type of property
investment that's a good property
investment a good deal but instead of
taking it on yourself you pass it on to
an investor and you charge them up take
so an average fee might be three
thousand pounds so what people are doing
is they're learning about property and
they want to invest themselves but they
haven't got too much money so instead
they're learning what property they're
finding deals and then they're selling
the deals to investors
and then they're making a living of
doing that or more than making a living
they're selling 10 a month making 30,000
pounds a month and then that money
they're they're using that to reinvest
themself into property and then there's
also a strategy which is one of my
favorites at the moment which we call
the B which stands for five refurbish
refinance rents what that means is you
buy a house and you normally buy
anything really bad condition and it's
people don't want it because maybe
there's weeds and and the toilets
horrible and there's just air horrible
and then you refurb it so you make it
look beautiful and have you spent twenty
thousand pounds making an absolutely
fantastic then you re mortgage the house
so you get a new mortgage on the house
and what happens is sometimes let's give
you an example if you buy a house for
80,000 you spend twenty thousand on it
but then it so you've entire you spent a
hundred thousand but then it's worth a
hundred and twenty five thousand so you
add even lifted the value you get a new
mortgage on the property and you pull
out pull back out all that money that
you put mm-hmm
and it's a way of buying houses with no
money don't make sense yeah so you need
money to start with but you put it in
you add the value and then you pull the
money back out huh
so basically you get all the money from
the bank yeah yeah and then you do it
again and again and again it's a bit
like buying and then adding value and
then selling at a higher price but
instead of selling and you keep it and
you just refinance it yeah so those are
the strategies buy-to-let
why refurbish should be financed rent
HMOs will rent to rents with Lease
Option agreements serviced accommodation
your packaging and sometimes you cook
you can combine strategies
[Music]